[Music]
the only thing better than zendaya and
tom holland pda is when it's birthday
pda can we just like stay up here all
day it is so crazy down there the
spiderman co-stars and real-life couple
were spotted in nyc holding hands and
enjoying some delicious coffee it's
amazing and we're guessing the caffeine
fix was probably because the night
before they were out celebrating zee's
26th birthday the day is good and it is
taken care of hanging with tommen
zendaya the actress's euphoria co-star
and close pal hunter schaefer she really
missed you
i really miss you too not only did
hunter celebrate with the birthday girl
in person she's legit like the most down
to purse down to earth person i've ever
met and just such like a beautiful soul
she also left a sweet comment on z's
birthday post a cute throwback pic of
her as a kid z gushed in her caption i
get to spend the day responding to the
most beautiful messages sorry i'm a
little late thank you all for filling my
heart with so much love i couldn't be
more grateful here's to 26. but hunter
was hardly the only star showing love on
z's pick victoria beckham carrie
washington naomi campbell and leslie
grace also sent their best wishes
i was um honored to say the least
no deo were honored that you were born i
think that might be true but we're still
waiting to see a birthday tribute from
tom it's great to have that support and
that love around you if it's anything
like the one he shared last year when he
wrote my mj have the happiest of
birthdays give me a call when you're up
we know it'll be just as cute i
appreciated you know the love that i got
from my loved ones and then also from
you know the world it was i felt
incredibly loved and grateful for for
all of that so you know i have no
complaints it was a great birthday and
now i'm here so
not bad 26 is shaping up to be zendaya's
best year yet after all the world and
tom are always cheering for her how are
you feeling about that and tackling that
they're losing things i think zendaya
just sounds like that there just showed
up
[Music]
you